Another question, if I started the higher dose of
eyebrows in two weeks, do the tumor markers that
enough time to show change? I don't know.
But in fact, I said, you know, you're on, you know, the,
if you're out of eyebrows, which, you know, the, all the
coercion, say it's out of chemotherapy, but truly it
really is. And actually, your tumor markers can go up.
It doesn't always, but they can spike. Again, that is really
why so many standard oncologists don't want to run
tumor markers, because they assume you're going to do what
they tell you to do, which is do chemo, and your two
markers can go up and then they have to have a sit down
with the patient and try to talk about the cliff, because
they're all freaked out, because the tumor markers went up
and I did doing this chemo. So I get it. So, but if there's
other signs that the cancer's growing, that's why he wants
to do the increased dosage and consider that.